thanks to curiosity stream and nebula
for sponsoring this video stick around
to the end for a whopping 26 discount
it's actually a different effect that
I'm getting on my screen because of the
oh that's so cool refresh rate
science
lots of people follow this YouTube
channel because of the Vlogs I made
during my PhD in atmospheric physics at
the University of Exeter unfortunately
however I had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a PhD was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting PhD projects and
so in this video series I'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
this episode I'm spending some time with
Kat who's studying for a PhD at the
University of bath and unusually is a
regular streamer on Twitch inspiring the
next generation of math students it's
freshers week here at the University of
bath but I'm not here for any of these
freshers behind me I'm here for a PhD
student someone who is studying
something that's actually very similar
to what I was doing my PhD on fluid
mechanics but whilst I was looking at
the big scale stuff in the atmosphere
she's looking at something a lot smaller
I'm Katie Phillips but I go by Kat I am
a second year PhD student at the
University of bath but I'm in my third
year of the samba CDT here which is the
statistical Applied Mathematics at Bath
Center of doctoral training and my PhD
research is in theoretical fluid
dynamics of impacting droplets so
picture I'm going to call it a bath but
just a very large body of water with a
small droplet above it and the droplets
falling so you can think of rain in a
puddle you can think of in the bath
splashing big body of water and then
droplet
a lot of current models so whenever they
look at this in for other reasons you
have a droplet that falls if it has
enough speed it bounces so you get
you've seen rain bounce and it
disappears and the models at the minute
just kind of only focus on the droplet
and the water because if you are someone
what am I looking at they would say
those two things but we don't live in a
vacuum so we have air as well and the
air is actually like incredibly crucial
to
the system because the air is the thing
that is stopping those two bodies of
water from coalescing mixing because as
soon as they touch it disappears and it
joins the bath so what my research is is
kind of considering this air layer like
actually putting it into the equations
like looking at what happens how the
pressure moves through the air does the
air like jettison out of the way does it
stay there and you actually end up with
this very thin band of air this entire
process and I'm trying to use
theoretical and numerical like modeling
to figure out what happens there this
Probably sounds rather abstract but cat
had a low-tech demonstration of what
this looks like practically and some
interesting things that can happen when
you mess with that bath so in our normal
system we have just a falling droplet
there you go
um but that is quite boring so what we
can do is stick our bath on top of a car
speaker so we put it on top of a car
speaker because we want to control the
frequency of it being shaken vertically
so I've attached it to an app on my
phone that has a frequency modulator and
that allows me to crawl how
um much we're shaking and how fast we're
shaking the bath there's a critical
frequency at which we can generate
surface waves so we can start seeing the
effect of shaking the bath but below
that so we're subcritical we get enough
energy to keep the droplets bouncing but
not so much to massively affect their
behavior as we increase the frequency we
start getting more chaos in the system
and we can get moving droplets and then
be on that again when we hit critical
frequency where we generate Faraday
waves on the free surface obviously we
could keep going and if we actually go
well beyond
um critical frequency we actually get so
much energy in the system that it can
generate droplets so they are called
um Faraday generated bouncing droplets
the thing that's really interesting
about this is the fact that you have
um what's called pilot wave phenomena
happening so you have the droplet which
is essentially a particle and you have
this
um the free surface acting as a wave
field that's kind of dictating the
movement and behavior of the droplet so
as the droplet bounces it's interacting
with the waves that it's generated
previously or the waves generated by
other droplets and that dictates where
it goes next what more serious
experimental setups have been able to do
is recreate Quantum phenomena such as
the double slit experiment so you can
recreate the double slit experiment
using this setup by putting two malls
submerged underneath the free surface
and as the waves on the top of the
surface move around they'll interact
with the walls underneath and you can
yeah get this double slit experiment
recreated so my work is trying to
describe what happens in the air and the
pressure transfer between the droplet
and the bath and so hopefully by the end
of the PHD I will have a system that but
feeds into models that describe the
walking and balancing Behavior so I fit
in on the micro scale where they model
the macro scale at the start of our
Theses they're encouraging everyone when
they write up to put in a responsible
research and Innovation
um section to be like why is your
research useful you can't just do
abstract Maths for no reason anymore
it's like what is this going to feed
into bigger models it can feed into like
oceanography because obviously you've
got rain and evaporation happening it
can feed into some really cool
theoretical problems and there's like
loads and just anything that has a very
thin layer of water or any water with
anything impacting on it you can have
boats impacting on like waves you still
get this thin layer of air protecting it
for us up to a certain point and my what
I'm doing will hopefully
better those models and make them more
accurate without being too heavy now if
you've seen some of my PhD Vlogs or
coding streams on twitch.tv4. Simon
Clark then you'll know that the
atmosphere is described using fluid
mechanics in fact it's described using
the exact same equation that Cat uses
the navier Stokes equation just with
different assumptions made and so
different terms in the equation ignored
so Kat and I geeked out on a whiteboard
talking about how you model the
atmosphere and how you model a water
droplet and what the differences are you
know for atmospheric stuff obviously
well most of the time you are interested
in time dependence yes but like actually
a lot of the time you can ignore it and
you just find like a balance like a
geostrophic balance for example but like
that's fair we're both on the same page
advection term absolutely important it's
something that's been killing me in my
own climate model this then becomes the
well actually you're also missing a term
from atmospheric science which is the
Coriolis term
so you'd have you know like a
um oh God this is where I get the
medicine so yeah there's a rotational
too there's a rotational term there and
and then you'd also have this would be
your gradient force in terms of just
your overall pressure gradient and that
also is probably the most important term
in terms of actually forcing you know a
domain yeah
um and then this is your viscosity term
yes so that can get in the bin no that's
the atmosphere is invisible there's no
imagine if the atmosphere was viscous so
in my air layer I would have inviscid
flow and in my liquid I now consider
small viscosity so obviously if it's too
viscous
um you don't get necessarily the right
surface tension into play right so the
crucial thing about this is it's
absolutely tiny if you have like a large
body impact it it's a different system
you'd have um gravity waves taking over
but because this happens this is like my
millimeters microbe like tiny stuff
um it's all capillary wave so it's
surface tension that's like the driving
force of why you get this bounce right
um so that can stay please okay um
have you watched any of this art
restoration YouTube channels oh yeah
restoration this is the mass version
so what's interesting to me at least is
that like it's the same equations that
get used in atmosphere in this kind of
context every flow mechanic context but
because of the assumptions you make no
two field uses the exact same equations
because you're binning you know
different terms yeah but like the actual
universality of the equation is just
really beautiful yes and it's one of the
things I love about fluids is because
you kind of no matter what physical
system you're given you start from the
same thing and then you can look at it
and start just making it nicer and nicer
to play with until eventually you have
an equation that is solvable by some
sort of numerical scheme you hope one
day one day one of the things when I was
finishing up my undergrad Masters was I
was looking through some of my old notes
from like when I was a small child in
school like year seven eleven or year
old or so
um and we found this mock interview that
we did to like prepare us for big school
and it was like what do you want to be
when you're older and I put researcher
as an 11 year old child I put researcher
I want to keep learning
and I don't think I ever really lost
that I think it definitely moved around
a bit as I grew up and
you know I think part of it was I wanted
to be an archaeologist or I wanted to be
Doctor Who and you know the the reason
why I wanted to research kind of changed
a bit but
I really liked learning I find I get
very excited whenever something works
also stem Ambassador so I do
um Outreach stuff targeted towards
children and I remember in my training
for that they brought up this stat of
the number of people interested in maths
at different key stages
um so you look at like five-year-olds 11
year olds 16 year olds and one thing is
there's a noticeable drop I think
there's something inherently wholesome
about small children if you like do you
like this they go yeah they don't know
what they're talking about but what was
interesting is you hit the 11 year old
Mark and suddenly it goes from pretty
equal split between the genders to a
massive drop
and is even more shocking when you hit
like 16 year olds and then suddenly by
the time you're hitting 18 year olds and
like how many of you are going to go do
you know stem or maths at University
you're hitting the like five percent
Mark and I think that's a really big
shame and I think it's a it's a societal
issue because something is happening
along there that is making girls and
women feel like they don't
they can't go into it I was really
fortunate that
I had an incredible maths GCSE teacher
who was female and she
just completely inspired me I love the
way that she tackled all the problems
she made classes really fun and then
again I was very fortunate at University
it was actually my third year fluid
dynamics lecturer um Dr Katarina Carey
who just completely inspired me I just
she was so great she was an incredible
teacher which is not something you can
say about every academic because the
teaching and the the lecturing side of
things is very different to being an
incredible researcher she was so great
about the way she spoke about things and
I genuinely don't know if I'd have
done as much or as well in my undergrad
and like wanted to do as much now and
wanted to share that as much if it
hadn't been for her so I know I was very
very fortunate to have those very you
know Wonderful female influences in my
life
um also my mum because I have to say
that because she's great we'll put that
in
now as a matter of fact I actually have
some history with the uni here because I
grew up about 15 minutes that way and
obviously as a kid you don't have much
reason to come up to the university but
my parents brought me here to learn how
to cycle so my very first ride ever on a
bike without stabilizers was down this
path which is a very
shallow incline so I came careening down
here at what I thought was tremendous
speed and then I collided
with a bin that used to be right where
that Lamppost is face first into a
rubbish bin
apparently my parents only fished me out
when they stopped laughing and I do know
that just over here just behind you
there are some signs
Wanderer
I don't know why those are there as I've
already mentioned it was freshers week
on campus when I filmed this which meant
that there were social events happening
everywhere but one social event that was
happening every week was in the maths
Department
every week we have one of the PhD
students come in and make a cake or
attempt to make a cake and it's just an
excuse in the middle of the week to like
get away and enjoy a break from work now
taking the view of the lay person a
gathering of a dramatic PhD students
sometimes maths not always we try and
have a band until one of the analysts
turn up and then suddenly it's pure
maths all the way the fact that the
tables are actually whiteboards so you
can write on the tables is quite fun
although if you do that in the pub they
get a bit angry at you you wouldn't do a
PhD if you didn't love what you do so
there is some talk on it but there's
also like sports and socials and we're
you know we're real people too there's
more than just math
shocking I know this is the bit that
gets me in trouble with my supervisor
for not spending nine to five on the PHD
I do tutoring for the University so I
teach the first year undergrads get them
into thinking about calculus and
differential equations I then do private
tutoring I then also help out at my
local yoga studio because when
everything moved online for them there
was a bit of a panic we hadn't been able
to do it over lockdown but there is a
group on campus called the
mathematicians excellent name I know so
they're a group that I kind of use the
stem ambassadorship for all my training
with that and we are hoping to be able
to go back into schools and do Outreach
days I then have a Twitch account cat
does maths where I kind of take
everything that I've learned from my
teaching and from my PhD and kind of
shove it into the general like public
audience and say hey look at this this
isn't scary maths is actually quite cool
I promise and this is how I originally
met cat through Twitch in case you don't
know twitch is a website where creators
live stream and interact with a chat in
real time original it was just used by
creators playing video games but now has
a community of streamers cooking playing
role-playing games and studying we both
do educational streams and both believe
that twitch can be used to great effect
in education such an untapped potential
for Academia to kind of bridge the gap
like showing my PhD research as I'm
doing it it's not scary well it might
look scary right now but it's not scary
because you can see me sitting there and
working through it and you can ask
questions you can talk to academics and
it removes this like stigma that
Academia is this scary building filled
with old white men that aren't going to
do anything except glare at you you know
like maths isn't
blackboards and grumpy people
there's a lot of that but it's not
exclusively and yeah I think Twitches is
beautiful like opportunity to actually
have
honest communication with people on what
it's actually like to see how cat went
about this I joined her for one of her
streams so what are we doing here what
stream are we doing okay so I call them
maths office hours which is basically my
attempt at
um shoving as much maths into the public
domain as possible so at the minute
we've been going through past papers of
AI romance one really nice comment I had
once from a follower that was just they
didn't understand it in school and they
hated it in school after watching my
stream they finally got it and they
really appreciated it and I was like
that's that's that's nice it's not just
people with like math Stockholm syndrome
no no hello there's two of us
um can we rotate the screen yeah like I
don't do what you like there we go just
I'll just cut me off there we go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my face
there we go that's just a bit better
okay I fixed it
um should we should we do something else
oh yeah so the first one that we've got
is given that Y is 2x squared minus 5x
find dydx from first principles we want
to find this gradient so whenever we
want to find
um
alignment we do things we do rise over
run so if we introduce the function at
this point is f of x plus Delta X okay
so that is then wherever there's an X
here we now have an X Plus Delta X so
that's going to be not plus equals two
two times this is now representing our X
so that goes in there so X Plus Delta x
squared
minus five lots of
that so X Plus Delta x squared plus 2 x
Delta X
plus Delta x squared thank you for
agreeing with me
I can see you nodding yes correct every
time we need to divide by something
we're getting there and it's minus five
would you like to continue so now
basically we then have to subtract from
this effectively you're taking this
expression and assuming that Delta X is
zero nearly but you need to subtract on
the top fist no no that's what I mean
but we're subtracting
so effectively we're subtracting 2x
squared
minus 5x yes from this so that just
leaves us with the terms that have the
Delta X and I'm going to write it like
this okay
if you have to it does say find dydx so
I'd Mark that wrong if I was marking
this one
so because you defined so if anything
I'd say that's your fault why because
you you substituted
y for a f yeah so Y is a function of F
so write that down anywhere did you what
did I just highlight
oh sorry this time when I'm defining
this is the setup this is the maths this
is the so we set d y d x formally to be
the limit as X Delta x times zero f of x
plus Delta x minus f of x over Delta X
which in this case is 4X minus 5.
goodbye
please end the stream I'm ending it
dang it that was chaos
it's completely chaos but like it was
really fun and like it's one of these
things where like if people are enjoying
themselves they look they stealth learn
yes yeah yeah if
it's full time like if say you know
something miraculous happens and you
know suddenly gain huge numbers of
followers and it becomes viable as a
full-time thing do you think you'd want
to do this over Academia
that's difficult because fundamentally I
want to do both yeah it's like I feel
like Outreach is
so so so important and full-time science
communicators and content creators are
absolutely invaluable to getting people
into it but then I also have this like
bit of me that loves what I do within
Academia but also feels like
for representation wise
it's all well and good saying you should
do this but then I wouldn't be doing it
myself yeah and like
if I did ever give up Academia for
something like this it's because this is
easier and I can curate my environment
much better and I feel like because I
love my research and I love like
teaching lecturing as well as messing
around for hours on this
I don't want to give that up for this
and I want like I want to be one of the
people when they're like oh you know I
have
three female lecturers this year like I
want to be one of those yeah and I want
to be like visible being myself but also
in an academic environment because I
feel like it's all well and good to
promote change outside of it and
encourage nude growth through life
fundamentally that's how we're going to
change the perception on Academia is by
the new people coming into it being
themselves and being different and being
a diverse group of people
but that's not good if then everyone
leaves at the highest level because all
you're left with that is the people have
been around for ages so I I love this
and I would want to do this at the very
least more seriously part-time but I
have always said I want to do Academia
and Outreach as like a mix of both
you're you're becoming the female
lecturer that you had at undergraduate
yes like a little bit because it was one
lecturer can Inspire even if it's two
students yeah it's worth it it's
expanding the representation yeah
definitely that's that's the goal at the
very so some some University give me a
job oh and in case you didn't pick up on
it cat is Welsh and so one of the
redeemable rewards on her twitch is
well Invasion has redeemed
um the Welsh name would you like to give
it a go oh is this the full
right
someone get ready to clip this please
what they're nailing uh yeah
[Music]
it's basically what I said
perhaps unsurprisingly when cat and I
got in front of a whiteboard we geeked
out enormously and I got her to explain
her work in way more detail than I could
ever fit into a YouTube video if you'd
like to see a bonus video of us talking
through the equations in her work then
that is available on nebula the
educational streaming service that I
co-own along with dozens of other
creators here we upload the videos that
we upload to Youtube but with extra
content and without any advert at all no
pre-roll ads and mid-roll ads no ads in
the videos themselves it's just the
thoughtful educational part of YouTube
with creators like Ali abdal Lindsay
Ellis and Jordan Harrod but with a
better viewing experience for you you
can download videos and watch them
offline and by watching a Creator you
directly financially support them and
help them make more content you can get
access by signing up with our partners
curiosity stream who curate the finest
library of documentaries on the internet
such as the beautifully produced
Butterfly Effect which includes an
episode code on the history of fluid
mechanics they have thousands of
professionally produced documentaries
available at your fingertips to
complement the Indie produced content on
nebula by signing up at
curiositystream.com Simon Clark you get
access to all these documentaries extra
content from Indie creators like me on
nebula and you also get an amazing 26
discount it works out at 14.79 a year or
a little over one dollar a month for the
version of YouTube that you probably
already watch but better and with access
to thousands of brain improving
documentaries that's curiositystream.com
Simon Clark with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
a massive thank you to cat for being so
generous with her time and allowing me
to join her on her stream I had a great
time making this video and I really hope
that you enjoyed watching it if you'd
like to see the previous videos in this
PhD Story series then check out the
playlist on screen right now along with
another suggested video if you did enjoy
the video please do pop it a like and if
you're not subscribed then consider
subscribing to find out when I release
more in this series thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one